valentine's Day is just around the
corner and if you have 16 million
dollars to spare Tom Brennan maybe I
have the perfect gift for you take a
look at this 100-karat graph vivid
yellow diamond unfortunately though
gentlemen it already sold for sixteen
point three million dollars last year at
auction but if you are in the market for
this kind of rock or perhaps I should
say glacier there is only one place to
shop and that is graph on rebar John is
the president and CEO of Graff diamonds
America's Henry thank you so much for
coming on thank you so much for lending
me this unbelievably gorgeous smile 9
million dollar 30 carat squares right
ring it's hard for me to sink while this
is on my finger but I would like to know
how strong how strong is the market for
a 10 million dollar ring actually
surprisingly enough the market is very
strong yeah I mean everything that is
really high-quality very rare stone the
demand not only in America but around
the world is quite how long is the list
of clients for something like this when
something comes into the store do you
already know who you're gonna call we
all yeah we are we have we have
obviously clients all around the world
and when we get such a rare stone which
obviously is not that often yeah we know
we know who to call who to speak to and
um Connery sometimes I'm amazing people
come on this show that there's a level
of luxury so high that before they come
on the show I didn't even know it
existed so graph was news to me for
which I apologize but you know other
than Olivia Sterns you don't generally
put your jewels on celebrities why not
no we don't because we are a very
high-end brand we sell an exclusive
product at very high prices do fantastic
people and I think that if I can loan it
or if anybody can borrow such expensive
jewelry it kind of defeats the purpose
eternal the ties of course but there's a
difference between I advertise because I
need my brand to be known and and I know
is I'm arriving for new clients why by
the emotional self to my client if
anybody can borrow it I'm sorry why buy
the cow when you can get the ice for
free but that's it that's a completely
different
okay what's the average price of a
transaction at Graff is it is 150,000
150,000 starts at 15,000 all the way up
to nine million or sixteen like I'm
sorry did you point her finger and say
nine million yes that's nine million
dollars it's a 30 carat gem oh my god I
talked about the low end of the market
you you sir you're the class act here of
bringing in one of your entry-level
diamonds which is $20,000 right yes why
should someone buy this gorgeous small
statement versus the ninety percent of
the riffraff that's out there sell me on
why I should step up to our entry-level
diamond versus the garbage that's out
okay I'll explain to you in two seconds
please because Laurence graphs passion
for diamonds all his life devoted all
his life to that and what we do the
magic is in the way you cut a diamond
this is what makes a difference where
they cut we have for cutting centers in
Johannesburg in Botswana in Antwerp and
in New York and when anybody let's say
from a three carat piece of rough he's
going to cut a one and a half carat or
1.7 meet your cat diamond Laurence
doesn't care if it only weighs one carat
but it's perfect perfect stone this is
why when people come to our stores
they're always amazed at how brilliant I
strode me they are they always think we
do something funny about the lighting no
it's because we cut them to perfection
that's what makes the difference in the
value have you ever had a customer faint
almost but I mean usually they manage to
keep going guys talking about the
colored stones because the colored
stones are even more expensive than the
clear ones I believe we have a chart
showing some of the most expensive
jewels you've ever sold we have a 31
carat blue diamond a 102 carat Graff
constellation classic and the yellow de
l'air sunrise what should we know about
these rocks well the blue stone is an
extremely rare diamond it was mined in
the late sixteen hundreds by Taveuni and
he sold it it's the same gentleman who
found the Hope Diamond and he sold the
vigils bar in the late sixteen hundreds
to the king of Spain and the stone is
actually an unbelievable story and we
bought it back four years ago if I go to
Tiffany's right now I can't buy anything
there are no rubies because of the
different bands on Burma and miR and
moths rubies how do you deal with that
do you tell a customer to go to Zurich
to buy a ruby or can they do it through
you here on Madison Avenue no in America
there is an embargo on on burmese ruby
the only way to find a burmese ruby is
on an antique piece of jewelry that was
that embargo working does it have any
validity when somebody can Maury Harris
once a ruby you can go to UBS London and
pick up the Ruby no you can always try
it and go around the system and do
whatever you want but as a jeweler I
cannot import a Burmese Ruby in America
it's against the law so that's that's
the end of it
mara Harris help me out here I'm
sandwich right now between a Bloomberg
monitor that shows GDP in America sort
of falling off a cliff and heading in a
new direction about five years ago and I
am looking at a nine million dollar
diamond and evidently demand for that is
unabated tell me what this means about
the American economy well what it means
is that there's a big difference between
wealth and income that in the last
couple of years you've had tremendous
booms in the property markets a
tremendous boom in the stock market so
the people who have benefited from that
can buy this gentleman's diamonds but
for the most part though the economy has
grown very slowly and most Americans
haven't seen their incomes go up but the
there's a very important wealth effect
that you've had the last couple of years
and people are spending that wealth on
his dime hurry tell me about the metal
that's on wrapped around the diamond is
white in now is yellow gold coming back
what's what's the thing people are
what's a trend right now no diamonds are
set white diamonds are second platinum
or white gold and pink and yellow
diamonds obviously you put you put a
yellow but gold the basket around it so
that it doesn't interfere with the color
of the stone what's your fastest-growing
market uh it was until a couple of
months ago it was Asia obviously and now
everybody in the luxury world seems to
have their eye on America yeah we we
kind of rediscover America don't forget
that 50% of all diamond jewelry in the
world is still sold in the USA only
thank you so much for loaning this
got to go off your print right now right
I know I've got to go don't worry I got
security back next week thank you so
much for joining us you're most welcome
thank you having